c'est encore un échec du gouvernement ça
va servir à rien ah non je ne pense pas
que c'est ça nous servit à rien je pense
même que c'est une étape importante
c'est une étape importante puisque la
première ministre souhaitait rencontrer
l'intersyndicale 570
000 manifestants selon la police moins
que la semaine dernière et même très
loin du Pic du 7 mars un million 280 000
personnes dans les rues selon les
autorités dès qu'elles seront prêtes en
discuter nous le ferons et d'ailleurs et
vous entendez ce qu'il vous répondent
ils disent pas question d'aborder les
autres sujets tant que la réponse
cette manifestation dégénérée vous voyez
les premiers projectiles et quand même
assez conséquent on a vu des pavés
atterrir aux pieds des des boucliers des
des policiers c'est pas la même chose de
se dire on sait parler mais on n'est pas
d'accord et de dire on n'est pas
d'accord mais on sait parler parce que
le contact est repris que le dialogue
existe et on voit les parapluies qui
sont ouverts je sais pas si vous les
voyez voilà ça c'est le précorté je
voyais les parapluies en fait ce sont
les individus ultra qui les utilisent
pour se cacher des caméras Olivero il a
rajouté une chose ce matin qui m'a qui
m'a fait sourire il a il a dit j'ai je
connais un peu je connais Laurent Berger
et je sais que au fond il est pas
d'accord avec lui
au bout d'un moment les gars j'ai envie
de leur dire écoutez les gars on va
poser les affaires alors que l'on voit
effectivement cette cette devanture ce
de la rotonde qui est en train de
prendre feu il devrait y avoir
l'intervention on imagine un des
pompiers assez prochainement
j'ai jamais manqué de respect à personne
mais arrêtez de penser pour moi ce que
je dis qui ne serait pas en phase avec
ce que je pense et tu as moi écoutez
vous aurais prévenu
ce type c'est bolsonaro et Trump c'est
ça son projet politique et il est pas le
seul il y en a plusieurs qui sont
candidats rôles
donc il est en danger pour notre
démocratie à l'époque des gilets jaunes
ce restaurant avait été vandalisé tout
comme le Fouquet parce que celle-ci
qu'un cap est franchi de s'en prendre à
ce restaurant symbolique vous craignez
d'autres incidents de ce type mais c'est
idiot il y a eu encore dans le cortège
parisien des des
dingues je sais pas comment les
qualifier non mais moi je souhaite pas
répondre à ces news et pourquoi parce
que en fait je vais pas sur sur vos
plateaux mais là c'est pour s'exprimer
devant tous les Français
nous donner vos revendications et ben
non voilà donc moi vous choisissez les
médias à qui vous vous adressez je
m'adresse à tous les médias qui la
preuve rien
non mais j'ai oublié on va reprendre la
parole parce que pour une démonstration
de pluralité qui vient d'être défendue
par Sophie Binet ça laisse quand même
sans voix donc on choisit
un appel à la communauté internationale
à garder la raison et la retenue et
s'abstenir de tout acte susceptibles de
conduire à une nouvelle dévoration même
à un thérapage de la crise je pense que
le Président de la République en Chine
il aurait peut-être dû plutôt que d'être
susceptible avec cette expression il
ferait mieux d'être un peu inquiet et je
sais pouvoir compter sur vous au titre
d'ailleurs des deux principes que je
viens d'évoquer pour
ramener la Russie à la raison et tout le
monde à la table des négociations un
look streetwear pourrait manuel Macron
affublé d'une doudoune noire et d'un
bonnet les outils d'intelligence
artificielle ont encore frappé avec
cette série de photos vers une possible
d'examen de
Gaëlle père de Rio le maire de
Saint-Étienne a été déféré ce matin au
de justice de Lyon pour être présenté un
juge il est poursuivi pour une affaire
de chantage politique à la sextape le
numéro de Playboy qu'il la mettant une
sort aujourd'hui en kiosque qu'on y
découvre la secrétaire d'État à
l'échoomi social et solidaire drapés
d'un drapeau français dans les pages
intérieures elle figurant en Europe
courtes ou très moulante mais pas nul
bien entendu dans l'Illinois une
habitante souffle coupée filme la
tornade
qui s'approche dangereusement
dans l'état voisins cette automobiliste
capture le tourbillon menaçant j'ai
contacté
son bureau et là ils m'ont dit mais
pourquoi pas l'idée n'est pour être
sympa allons plus loin et là une autre
tornade se dessine à l'horizon